At least 100 billion galaxies in the observable universe.
There are nearly 500 billion planets in the Milky Way alone,
and at least 10 billion of them are earthlike all these planets,
and yet we've discovered exactly zero alien life forms.
But what if we did?
What if NASA announced that they found microbes and the oceans of Europa or
ancient alien ruins on Venus?
What would that mean to our human civilization here on earth?
Would we consider that good news?
This is what if,
and here's what would happen if we discovered alien life
since humans began searching for extraterrestrial life within our solar system
in the 1890s we're still waiting to encounter an alien life form.
But if we did find one,
that would be very bad news because in that case we might as well be dead.
It wouldn't look anything like the alien invasion.
You might imagine
nobody would blast.
They're super advanced weapons at us,
hopefully not.
Even if they did,
it wouldn't be that much of a problem because by the time we found alien life,
we'd already be on our way to self destruction,
all because of the great filter.
What kind of filter is capable of killing our entire civilization and why?
Let me go back a little bit.
Basically probability asserts that alien life must exist somewhere in the
universe.
If that were the case,
wouldn't we be able to see some signs of life out there,
but we don't.
The university seems endlessly empty.
It's this contradiction.
It's been blowing scientists minds ever since.
They realize that the universe is very,
very big.
They called it the Fermi paradox.
It also says that all species in the universe go through the same evolutionary
path,
no matter where they're from.
First,
the development of life anywhere in the universe starts with the right star
system,
planet that has just the right conditions.
Then organic compounds assemble themselves into self replicating patterns and
eventually evolve into more complex multicell organisms all the way up to the
species with the big brain that eventually take over their own planet and change
it according to their needs here on earth.
That happens to be us humans.
Then there's the last step space colonization.
That could happen for many reasons,
overpopulation and the need to spread out to survive conquest of solar systems,
one after another,
or even simple curiosity,
whatever the reason is,
all civilizations,
we'll end up trying to call a nice space.
Some alien species may have been around for billions of years longer than us,
but they still haven't shown up here on earth.
Looks like something is making it very hard to colonize a galaxy,
maybe even impossible.
It's a great filter.
Yup.
The thing that might wipe out all of humanity,
it's something very dangerous.
Something that happens to every civilization that's advanced enough to go beyond
their planet.
One of the steps on evolutionary path,
something that takes maybe billions of years to go through.
Having never met life on other planets means that the hypothesized great filter
didn't wipe us out.
Instead,
we might be the first civilization to pass it safely and the first to reach this
level of technology in the entire universe,
but just because we haven't seen them,
it doesn't mean they don't exist or never existed.
There's a chance of some aggressive alien species might've been on the way to
earth to destroy us all,
but since they never showed up on our planet,
that means something destroyed their entire civilization before they reached
earth.
The great filter,
it doesn't look like we're going to find anyone as advanced as we are.
If there was a more advanced civilization than ours,
we'd know it by now.
The most we can hope for is bacteria on Mars or multicellular animals in the
oceans of Europa.
Both options would be disturbing,
but the worst thing to find would be the ancient ruins of an advanced alien
civilization because if they didn't get past the great filter,
neither did we.
The only difference is that they're long dead and we're just on our way to self
destruction.
The more complex and advanced the discovered alien life was more likely it would
mean that we're behind the great filter.
Maybe that filter starts once the species take control of their own planet.
Ai destroying its creator,
genetic engineering gone wrong,
climate change.
It could be anything.
It might have happened to those dead alien civilizations and might happen to us
too.
Alien life might sound like the most exciting discovery of our time.
However,
it might be better for us if the universe is absolutely sterile aisle and that
there are billions of new planets to be discovered and terraform,
but that's a story for another.
What if.